from time to time people give me samples
of elements but it's not very often that
I get two samples and even rarer that I
get two samples that are very different
but with zirconium I've had one sample
which is big lumps of metal this comes
from a company that supplies large
quantities of specialist metals to
customers the other sample is a very
fine powder of zirconium which was sent
to me by technician at San Paul's School
in London and I've given the powder
sample to Neal to see what he can do
with it so Neal what are you going to do
with this powder this sample is
interesting first of all because it's
relatively light
Ciccone 'm is in the middle of the
periodic table and so although these
look large lumps they're not very heavy
they usually fill
Ciccone 'm has one particular
application which is it is used for
cladding of nuclear fuel in nuclear
reactors these samples came from Russia
which specialize in making zirconium in
fact you may have seen from some of my
earlier videos I have a vodka glass also
made from zirconium it's not a glass it
so vodka container and when I need
cheering up I drink from it but the big
problem of zirconium is separating it
from hafnium so with my sample came a
really quite comprehensive analytical
data of all the different elements that
they've tested for and if you look down
these numbers here in the columns are in
parts per million and they're all very
very small there's a tiny amount of
tellurium or barium or neodymium but
when you get to hafnium here it's got
really quite a lot 250 parts per million
and the reason why you need to purify
the hafnium is because in nuclear
applications hafnium can absorb neutrons
and therefore could spoil the behavior
of the fuel in the nuclear reactor it's
hard to separate because hafnium and
zirconium are in the same group of the
periodic table and their chemical
properties are very similar when two
elements have similar chemical
properties they're always hard to
separate
nice the fuel in a nuclear reactor is
usually some form of uranium oxide which
cannot be made into nice rods so you put
them essentially into a cang rather
similar to my vodka glass but a long
tubular can which gives them the
mechanical rigidity so you can lower
them in and out of the nuclear reactor
the outer coating is made out of
zirconium the problem comes when things
go wrong in the nuclear reactor because
at very high temperature
zirconium can react with the steam in
the nuclear reactor the stink is comes
from the water that is used to cool the
reactor and zirconium can extract the
oxygen from water to make Saucony mach
side and hydrogen so you can generate
saucony oxide which causes the fuel rods
to start falling to bits and at the same
time hydrogen which can mix with air and
explode and you will have seen pictures
of exploding nuclear reactors for
example Chernobyl or more recently at
Fukushima because of this reaction
between fuel cladding and steam
why don't we make not use echo view in
our cladding well zirconium has the
right properties too from the nuclear
point of view and many other elements
also react with steam at high
temperature I on does for example and
iron rusts as well so that would be even
more problems so you can't go get round
the fact that most metals at high
temperature will form oxides ciccone IAM
oxide is actually quite an abundant
material apparently there's some beaches
in Australia in the northern part which
are the sand is mostly zirconia Setsuko
nem oxide so it's a really quite
abundant element so it's not going to be
one that is going to run out very soon
compared to some of the other really
rare elements
you